And who kills the men who are victims of murder?
Is it. Is it women or?
Mostly men. If men didn't exist,
there would be virtually no victims of murder.
And often
men who are violent towards men have been violent towards women first.
It's actually a predictor of being a mass shooter.
And actually, if we took violence against women seriously,
we probably be able to prevent so many more mass shootings,
many men dying at the hands of other men.
So, yeah,
a lot of men are victims of murder because violent men murder them.
And if you want less violent men in the world,
maybe you should join a movement.
Uh, it's called the feminist movement.
Cause we've been working on this stuff for a long time.
And instead of making our efforts harder with comments like this,
maybe you could join us. You know,
we really guys like you making it easier for us to save your life.
That'd be just great.